So yeah, I'll focus on epigenetic modification in T cell lymphomas and some of the older
strategies and some of the newer strategies with that.
These are my disclosures.
And then objective, because we're talking about epigenetic dysregulation, I think TFH
lymphomas will be the focus.
And we'll be talking about the two main trials, the ROCHOP trial and the ORACLE trial.
And then also end with emergence of the EZH1-2 inhibitors so far that we know of.
Okay, so there was a major update in the classification of PTCL subtypes, especially in the 2022 WHO
edition.
All the basically angiomelblastic T cell lymphoma, follicular T cell, and PTCL with TFH phenotype
were all just categorized as nodal TFH lymphomas.
Either angiomelblastic, follicular type, or NOS.
So that was a major change.
As we know, these nodal TFH lymphomas are characterized by epigenetic mutations, especially
TET2, DNMT3A, IDH2, and ROA.
And obviously those are common and may predict responses to epigenetic therapies.
They also, there was a change in terms of
having a category called primary nodal EBV, EBV positive lymphomas also with this edition.
So focusing more on the AITL.
So AITL is a very complex, it's, it's, the pathogenesis is complex because there's a
lot of interplay between the follicular helper T cells and the germinal center B cells,
the T cells, eosinophils.
CXCL, CXCL13 is released by, by the TFH cell, which helps actually,
in recruitment of the germinal center B cells.
So there's, there's a lot of interplay.
There's increased production of VEGF, which leads to angiogenesis and overall leads to
development of this, this lymphoma.
If we look at mutational hierarchy, the, the mutations such as TET2 and DNMT3A are
common at the progenitor level and later cells can derive other mutations.
That can lead to either myeloid malignancies or lymphomas.
So if you have TET2 or DNMT3A mutation, that's passed on to the, the lymphoma progenitor cells,
you do require the second hit with either ROA, IDH2, CD28, or PLC-gamma mutations to develop AITL.
If you develop, sorry, not one mutation, then it will lead to development of truly a
B-cell lymphoma, which we see sometimes with AITL.
So looking at the treatment pathways, there's many, many treatment pathways that are
obviously being targeted for PTCL.
And I'm not going to go over all of them, but obviously PI3 kinase pathway is important.
JAK2 inhibition is important.
We talked about the CD30 targeting, but if you go inside the nucleus, what I want to focus on is
three main pathways.
One is demethylation with the DNMT3A inhibitors.
We got HDAC inhibitors and then EZH1 slash 2 inhibitors.
So HDAC inhibitors, which increase the acetylation and result in gene activation,
have been very effective in PTCL.
I guess I wouldn't, I shouldn't say very effective, but they're more,
more effective in AITL subtype than other T-cell lymphomas.
And, you know, obviously this is the mechanism of how they work.
If you inhibit the HDAC, which will result in hyperacetylation of the DNA,
which will open up the DNA for reading and will activate tumor suppressor genes.
Multiple retrospective studies have shown,
that these HDAC inhibitors are very effective in TFH type of lymphomas.
Now, this is something that we found out recently, probably in 2018, 2019, 2020.
But before that was known, a clinical trial was designed called the RhoCHOP versus
CHOP trial, RhoCHOP trial, where romodepsin was added to CHOP.
Now, because we didn't know about the activity,
we didn't know about the activity, we didn't know about the activity,
of the HDAC inhibitors in TFH lymphomas,
this trial was not stratified based on the TFH versus non-TFH.
So although there were about 50% of the patients who had AITL in both arms,
it did include other 50% of patients who had PTCL-NOS or anaplastic large cell lymphoma.
With that, the results were,
they showed that the median progression of resurvival was slightly improved with the RhoCHOP,
but it was not clinically or statistically significant, 12 versus 10 months.
And then the overall survival was the same also.
The investigators went back and looked at just the TFH phenotype of lymphomas recently.
And at that point, they did find that if you add romodepsin to CHOP for specifically the TFH
lymphomas, then the PFS is improved.
So the results were 19.5 versus 10.6.
But obviously, this is a post-hoc analysis.
And because of that, it hasn't really made any guidelines.
Similarly, if you look at azacitidine, which is obviously inhibitor of DNMT,
that has been compared to standard of care, specifically in the TFH phenotype lymphomas with this trial.
So this trial only included patients who had TFH phenotype lymphomas.
So this trial only included patients who had TFH phenotype lymphomas with this trial.
So this trial only included patients who had TFH phenotype lymphomas, which predict for hopefully
better responses with hypomethylating agents.
And the standard of care was either benamastine, romodepsin, or gemcitabine with this.
And with this study, there was improvement in PFS of 5.6 versus 2.8 months.
But the way that the trial was designed, the p-value needed to be less than 0.025
to meet statistical significance, which it did not.
But to me, I think this shows that this treatment is actually effective in a lymphoma that really doesn't have many options.
There was also improvement in overall survival, obviously too early to tell, but there was improvement of about eight months.
One of the other things that we learned from this trial is that it proved the mutations that we already knew about with TFH lymphomas,
most common ones were TET2, almost about 80%, followed by the ROA, IDH2, and the DNM2/3A mutations.
And lastly, I want to focus on the EZH1/EZH2 inhibitors.
So PRC2 complex is important for trimethylation of the histone H3, which shuts down transcription
and decreases the tumor suppressor effects.
And EZH1 and EZH2 are super important.
So if you have a drug that can inhibit this PRC2 complex, which would hopefully result in less trimethylation
and activation of the transcription, that would result in more tumor suppressive effects.
So with that, while metastat was investigated in a large phase two study, where overall responses
were quite good for PTCL/TFH phenotype or AIT.
And we were able to find out that the PTCL/TFH very good for PTCL/TPH phenotype and AITL almost 50% to 60%.
Including some CR rates.
Although this has been published, it has not made the NCCN guidelines,
nor is it FDA approved.
And currently, I'm not aware of where this drug is going in terms of further development
for T cell lymphomas.
A case scenario that I just wanted to briefly go over was, we had a patient who had multiple myeloma and they had, you know, we had a patient who had multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma and they had, you know, multiple myeloma.
And they had CAR-T for that, cetaceol.
And we know about this entity of, you know, T cell lymphomas deriving from CAR-T,
especially there's been some publication with cetaceol.
And this patient actually developed PTCL/NOS.
And when they were diagnosed, they had multiple TEP2 mutations.
We treated the patient with BVCHP, patient was quite frail.
It was too toxic and it didn't work.
And
it's
sort of
a
lot,
it's sort of a lot,
it's sort of a lot, last-ditch effort.
We put the patient on Tazmetastat,
just single agent EZH2.
And that resulted in a really, really remarkable response at three months.
Although it was not, it was short lived.
And then lastly, I think Dr.
Amiguel went over this study with ETCTN where
they were combining HTAC inhibitor with EZH2 inhibitor.
It has shown good outcomes.
However, this study is closed now due to
safety related
concerns with Tazmetastat.
So with that, you know, this is my current management of systemic PTCLs.
I still consider CHOP or CHOAP
in absence of clinical trials for TFH phenotype or PTCL/NOS.
And for ALCL, I either consider BVCHP or BVCHEP,
followed by auto only for the ALK-negative ALCL patients.
There is a major cooperative group trial
that's trying to combine either Duolacib or azacitidine
that's undergoing and that is, it is stratifying patient based on TFH versus non-TFH.
So I think that will be important
once that trial gets going a little bit further.
And then for relapsed refractory,
I think I sort of put them in a bucket of eligible versus ineligible.
I try to use doublets or chemo for transplant eligible patients.
And for transplant ineligible patients, I try to use single agents.
Thank you.